okay so welcome everyone to the first
talk uh for our first speaker we have
iridium from the weizmann institute
who is an expert on computational
complexity in general and pcp theorems
in particular
and she will be delivering the
introductory lecture
of our pcp mini course
okay so hi everyone um
i'll be shutting off my camera i just
wanted to say hi
at least so you can see me but i have
some wi-fi
issues so i'm gonna leave the meeting
and
from my mac and just remain on my
ipad
okay all right
so uh hopefully you can still hear me
um
so we have a sequence of four lectures
crash course on pcps and
i'll start with the first lecture which
will be very introductory
kind of setting up what pcps are
and the context hardness of
approximation
and going into parallel repetition
our uh the way we designed
the four lectures with dana moscovitz
the first two lectures are more
introductory and the second two
are more um
[Music]
kind of designed to be to
describe areas that touch as much as we
see on uh topics of high dimensional
geometry that might be interesting for
the
specific program that we are taking part
of
so there are many geometrical questions
uh the lectures on friday and monday
will be
touching more on these kinds of aspects
today will be more introductive
so let me start by describing
a a three coloring
which is an np problem
now i'm not assuming people have a
strong complexity background and i i'm
not interested in giving a complexity
definition so
the best way i've found it to describe
the pcp theorem is
to give a more a concrete example for
example three coloring
so what is recoloring we have a graph a
vertices and edges so the graph can
look something like this
[Music]
maybe these are the edges
this is a graph and it's
three a three coloring is a just a
coloring of the vertices in three colors
so a
three coloring is some string c in
zero one two these are the colors raised
to the power of v so every vertex
receives a color
and the coloring is a considered to be a
legal coloring
if c is
valid if for every edge
uv and c of u
is different from c of v so every edge
these two distinct
colors okay so let's see if this graph
is
uh three colorable so i can color this
vertex red and then i can color this one
blue
and then i can color maybe this one
orange
and i can keep going like this so this
one can be red
maybe this one will be blue this one red
and then i reach this last vertex and i
see that it has three neighbors
one is red one is orange and one is blue
so
i cannot there is no way i can
color this vertex uh
properly if i if i choose to color it
red for example
then uh this edge will be uh
okay wait how do i do this this edge
will be bichromatic this edge will be
seeing two different colors but this
edge
will be a red and red
okay so this graph is actually not
so this graph is not it's recolorable
but there is something interesting about
this graph
notice that the number of i had one
vertex in the middle
and there were an odd number of vertices
around
uh that were all connected by a cycle so
really the
this graph is supposed to hint at a
graph that is
a cycle of of odd length of growing
length
and all the vertices in the cycle are
connected to a central vertex
this this such a graph is almost
recolorable it's not recolorable for the
same reason that this
example is not but there is a three
coloring which i just drew
which violates only one single edge
so in some sense you can say oh it's
almost recolorable because
there is a coloring that satisfies
almost all of the
validity constraints every edge is
happy except for this one unhappy edge
okay and this is kind of a demonstrating
some
[Music]
important aspect of a constraint
satisfaction problems
uh which we will now
discuss okay but before we discuss them
i just want to say that
what we what we are seeing here is
a a combinatorial problem it's
recoloring
uh and i described it as you know every
edge needs to see
two different colors but of course you
can view it as a special case of
what we call a csp a constrained
satisfaction problem
where we're looking at assignments to
some variables
here the variables are on the vertices
and the assignment is supposed to give
the variables colors
and we have a bunch of constraints here
every edge poses a constraint and the
constraint says
this color should be different from that
color so these are inequality
constraints but in general csps can have
more there's a huge variety of
problems that fall into this uh general
notion of constraint satisfaction
problem
okay for example the constraints can be
dnf clauses boolean clauses like in
threesat
they can be cnf clauses they can be um
linear equations over some finite field
um so there are many many different
examples of constraints distraction
problems and
for all of them whatever i'm going to
say is relevant so let me
tell you a couple of examples of csps
one is uh threesat so threesat
we're all very familiar right you you
have some variables like
x1 or not x2 or
x7 this is one constraint
and then we have many more like this
okay so this is a constraint
satisfaction problem
and maybe another kind of constraint
satisfaction problem is
thrilling where the constraints are of
the form
x1 plus x 3 plus
x4 equals 1 mod 2.
so these are linear equations and maybe
you have another one
and this is another kind of constraints
at this factoring problem
so these are all problems that are uh
problems in np in the sense that um
if you give me a solution to to one of
these problems it's easy for me to check
them
so let me say that
i forgot to say it about spray coloring
so three coloring
and similarly all csps
is in np which means that if you give me
a coloring to the graph
you tell me every vertex what color it
is it's very easy for me to go edge by
edge
and check that this coloring is proper
is valid so
there's a polynomial time algorithm for
checking that the coloring is okay
but if you ask me to
find the coloring you give me a graph
and you ask me can you please
give me a coloring three coloring of
this graph
then we don't know of a way to do it
and it's believed to be impossible
if you managed to find a way to do it
this would prove that p equals
np this problem is not only in np it's
actually
np hard
and the meaning of this is that any
other
any other problem in np
can be encoded or recast
into this problem
meaning that if someone found an
algorithm for finding a three coloring
of a graph of an arbitrary graph
then immediately you can use that to
solve any other problem in
in nt so that's the meaning of being
np hard here and
so we saw this example of this graph if
you look at this graph it's not so
hard to convince yourself that it's not
recolorable and to
prove it to yourself but when we say
that recoloring is np hard it means that
generally when we get a graph
of uh a large number of vertices
there is no efficient way for us to
decide if it is or it isn't
three colorable so uh it's
it's like it's the graph is out there in
the open
but the answer whether it's recolorable
or not is totally
hidden
and if you think about a given graph for
example
look at the graph that i drew here the
set of
colorings it's you can think of it as
some geometric set 0 1
2 to the power of v so it's a set of
strings
okay and every string you can attach to
it
the number of edges that it violates
okay
so you have some kind of a landscape
where for every point in the space
there is some energy value which says
how many
constraints are being violated and
if a graph is recolorable or not it's
just whether or not there's a point that
has
zero violations somewhere
right and the way um
a graph defines this set of
valid strings in an implicit way by a
set of
equations so np sets are always this
kind of
sets they are always defined implicitly
by a set of equations and we are
trying to see for example the
at least for me it's frozen on the uh
at the very beginning with the graph of
the picture of the three coloring graph
ah okay yeah yeah yeah i think this is
how i put it that because i was just
trying to
thanks for asking at least i know
someone is out there because i'm not
seeing you guys
so uh please do interrupt me and i'm
just talking about
i was putting this on the screen because
i wanted to have a graph in mind
okay got it sorry maybe i should do this
so you know i'm here
yeah yeah okay
okay so um
to to finish just this this uh short
introduction to
uh constraint satisfaction problems i'm
sure a lot of you are familiar with it
but as a boot camp i
i found it necessary to define this
when i think of the set 0 1 2 raised to
the power of v
it's a set of strings and i can think of
two different
measures on it one measure is just
if you look at two strings i can measure
their distance and how many
vertices do they agree so maybe i start
with some coloring and i flip
one color i get to another coloring okay
so they're very close to each other
they're only one vertex apart that's one
kind of
measure on colorings and another one is
the measure of how many edges are being
violated
okay and sometimes
you get a graph and you find a coloring
that's almost
a three coloring for example the
coloring we have here
satisfies almost all of the edges except
for one
so you might uh kind of naively expect
that oh okay if i can on
already almost satisfy all the
constraints then i can probably just
play a little bit and maybe flip one of
the colors
and change it a little bit and i will
get a perfect coloring
but in this example you see how brittle
it is you can satisfy almost all of the
edges but there is no way to satisfy
all of the edges so so a lot of uh
graphs and a lot of csp instances have
this property
that they're very brutal in this way
satisfiability you you seem as if you're
approaching it but you're really not
however in the kind of instances that
the pcp
theorem generates this is not the case
uh the pcp theorem it tells you that
actually not only is three coloring np
hard but actually
uh there is a mapping that takes
[Music]
for example three coloring but it can
take any other np language
into a set of instances that have this
robustness property so let me tell you
what i mean here this is still
probably quite vague and i will soon
become more formal the pcp theorem
is an algorithm we call it a reduction
okay it's a reduction algorithm
that maps a graph g
to another graph let's call it pcp of g
all right denoted by g
tilde okay and it's it's a polynomial
time algorithm it takes the
initial graph and outputs another graph
and it has this special property that if
g was
recolorable then
also the the new graph will be three
colorable
and if g is not
then the new graph not only it's it's
not three color but like in our example
but
actually it's very far from three
colorable okay
it's a far in what in what distance
in the sense that no matter how you
recolor it many
like one percent fraction of the edges
will
be unhappy we'll see the same color on
both end points
okay so it's far configurable namely let
me call it that the value
of g tilde is less than 0.99
where what is the value
of a graph it's the maximal
fraction of
valid a
edges when i instead of valid let me
write
bichromatic by
chromatic so when i say
maximal fraction i mean overall
over all signs
assignments overall colorings
okay so
if you give me a graph i can ask if it's
recolorable or not but i can
ask even something more refined which is
okay over all the possible ways i can
recolor this graph
every three coloring violates some
fraction of edges and i want the one
that violates
the fewest or in other words satisfies
the most
edges and this is the value of g tilde
so
theorem just tells me oh you know it
could be that initially if i look at all
possible graphs
some of them are even though they're not
recolorable they're very close to this
they they can be very misleading and
they can be
like in my example they can have a
coloring that's almost
it satisfies all the edges except for
one so these are like these brittle
graphs that
will confuse me the pcb theorem tells me
oh but there's a polynomial time
algorithm that takes your graph and
changes it in a way that now the output
is guaranteed to have this property that
if
initially you were in a non-recoverable
situation then now you're in a very
strongly non-very colorful situation
okay so that's all good and well
now why would i care about this kind of
transformation
so uh this leads me
back to kind of the way the pcp theorem
was conceived and
formulated and proven initially this was
a
line of proof that started in the late
80s and
came from a crypto and let me call it
a
the dramatized dramatized i don't know
if this is a good name or not
a perspective
on pcps okay so far the perspective i
gave
you read there's a question in the q a
that might be good live at
uh the question asked does 0.99 depend
on the graph g
oh okay great so thanks for the question
so there was a 0.99 here
here uh sine does not depend on the
graph g
thanks so uh the
way this theorem should read is an
algorithm and with the algorithm comes
the number
0.99 it's a guarantee of the algorithm
so that for every graph
you g you get g tilde and you have this
property
okay so that's actually the strength of
the theorem
that uh g can grow the number of
vertices can go to infinity but there is
still one
percent of the edges that will always
cry out you know i'm i'm seeing the same
color on both endpoints
where whereas without the pcp theorem
there there's always going to be one
edge that cries out but as a percentage
it will be
a negligible percent of the edges when
the graph goes to infinity
does this answer the question
well the person who asked the question
isn't able to speak but i think so
yeah absolutely yeah i mean i i just
interjected because i thought it might
be a good question other people might
have too
thanks
certainly i can't see the questions
unfortunately so thanks for
uh yeah calling them out please so we
have some more questions in the chat
some of which dana has already
uh answered on the chat but uh but you
can
answer them also if you like uh so
someone asked how much bigger made
gtaled be than g
um and whether 0.99 okay so how much
bigger my
detail right so these are excellent
questions and
i'm i'm going to get back to them soon
okay but first we're going to do a
interlude to the dramatized perspective
on pcps
okay and we'll get to these questions so
i won't forget
okay so uh so far we talked about
uh graphs or maybe system of constraints
and their solutions and how many
uh constraints are being violated or not
violated so this is kind of a
mathematical or static view
now there's a different way to view
these things which is more
personified or dramatized perspective
which is more natural sometimes this
perspective is very useful
people use it a lot in in different
areas and in tcs it's been very useful
specifically in crypto so you have
entities like you have
maybe approver and you think of this as
like a person
right and you have a verifier and
when people talk about them they say you
know the prover thinks this and that
but the verifier doesn't want the prover
to cheat so it's all very dramatic
and they interact and so these guys they
interact with each other
sometimes there's more than one prover
and also maybe the verifier
has some randomness
and those of you who haven't uh heard a
lot of
cryptocurrencies maybe don't know but
this was like a hugely new thing
in in the 80s where these kinds of
things were explored more
rigorously and formulated and this led
to
so many beautiful things actually i'm
sure that everyone has heard about this
but uh nevertheless a
one of the things that uh turned out is
that indeed when the verifier has a
randomness
then the kind of the interaction between
the verifier and the approver
can become much more interesting and
surprising
in in in the power that the verifier has
okay so let's
uh let's return and see what np looks
like
in a dramatized perspective so the
prover is pretty
static the approver just writes the
proof and goes away so instead of
approver really what you have is a proof
so we start with a verifier that
didn't work okay
so here is my verifier and the verifier
is always
like an algorithm it's computationally
it's uh it's supposed to be efficient
like an algorithm
and the verifier receives an input for
example a graph
uh you know that it needs to decide if
it's three color level or not
and the verifier also has access to a
proof okay
so here is the proof no it's
disappearing
here is the proof okay
so the approver wrote down the proof and
left the room
and the verifier can read the proof
so in an np in an enquiry problem in
np a language or problem
the this picture is supposed to describe
the following situation
first thing the verifier reads the input
verifier
reads input and think of the input as
some
graph g okay so it's a graph g that the
verifier needs to decide if it's three
colorable or not
okay then the verifier
reads the proof
so in our case if it's a three colorable
if it's recoloring then the proof can be
for example a string
in 0 1 2 to the v
so it's just a coloring of the vertices
so think of this as a string
where every symbol here is just a color
this is one
this is two this is zero this is zero
and these are just the colors of all the
vertices this can be a proof
okay and then the verifier decides
decides if to accept or reject so it
computes and it says
yes or no output
yes or no so this is the output yes or
no
okay and in np in an np language the
property is that
uh if g is recolorable
then there exists some proof pi such
that maybe i don't have enough space
here so let me actually
uh do it uh
do it like this
make everything look smaller okay
so there exists a proof pie maybe i
write here the word proof
such that the verifier
says yes okay
if of course there is right the proof
would just be a three a proper three
coloring of the vertices and the
verifier
uh how does the verifier decide if to
decide if to output yes or no the
verifier just goes edge by edge
and checks that the endpoints of each
edge are different colors if yes it will
say yes
and if g is not recolorable
then for every proof so no matter how
you give me a coloring of the vertices
so it's for every proof the verifier
says no
because there will always be some edge
where it sees that the two endpoints are
the same color this is just in this
example of recoloring
but as i told you this problem is np
complete so
it encodes any other np language so i'm
not losing any generality but just
talking about this
seemingly very specific problem
now what is the pcp
version of this interaction so we said
that there is randomness right so
we add to this picture this uh
we denote we sometimes draw it by a
random
coin so people like to put a dollar for
the randomness
and you add some randomness to the
verifier so the verifier doesn't just
do everything deterministically but
rather it has some a randomness
okay so the verifier reads the input
then here it's step 1.5
it tosses some random bits
the number of random bits is actually
this is important it should be
logarithmic
in the size of the input so in our case
if we have a
graph of size something n let me denote
it by n
so logarithmic in n where n is the input
size
okay so it has some random bits and then
um
it doesn't have to read the proof all of
the proof anymore this is what's
initially was so amazing actually the
verifier reads only part of the proof
part i should i'm writing too small now
part of the proof
okay so
it can decide to maybe only read this
part of the proof
or maybe if the random string said
something else it would read this part
of the proof so
really what's the verb the verifier is
doing you should think of it as a
distribution
over many many different uh verifiers
depending on the random bits right so
it's really a distribution it's a
this randomized the verifier is a
distribution over different
uh
kind of different ways the coin tosses
fell
okay and for each different coin toss
the verifier ends up deciding yes or no
so in the end i need to
think about the probability that the
verifier said yes and the probability
that it said no so now if i go to
to uh to this uh
these conditions previously we said if g
is recolorable
there exists a proof there exists a
proof by such that the verifier says yes
now i cannot anymore say something like
verifier says yes because the verifier
is
probabilistic so instead i i write
uh the probability that the verifier
says yes
is one okay so that's
in in the us case i want i this now i'm
kind of
making some kind of definition so i want
a proof system where
if g was three colorable there will be a
proof causing the verifier to always say
yes no matter what the coin tasks were
and if g is not recolorable i want it
for every proof
again now i cannot talk about what the
verifier is doing except
with probability i wanted the fraction
of
coin tosses that caused the verifier to
say no
is not negligible previously it was zero
now it should be non-negligible or
really the way we we like to
uh to write it is we always talk about
the probability of saying yes
now it should be less than okay and
hint is it's the same 0.99 as before
uh so let's let's see why um
okay so let me just say so what is the
so so far
i described this
i think i think there's a question that
it might be worth answering
live just to clarify for everyone so
anonymous attendee asks
is the proof a general algorithm or a
string relative to a specific
g
is the proof so the proof has an
existential a quantifier and then a
for all quantifier so the the proof you
don't
need to think about it as an algorithm
it's uh the prover is almighty and
the proof can be anything i mean like in
np the
the guy that generates the coloring for
you uh
can be doesn't have to work in any kind
of bounded
computational time i'm not
not sure if i understand any question i
think maybe it's it's good to say that
there's a protocol
that both the prover and the verifier
are going to follow but they can handle
that protocol applies to any input
but the provers protocol doesn't have to
be efficient
right sure
okay hopefully sorry hopefully maybe
it'll be
clear in a minute sorry
oh go ahead sorry
it's okay yeah i i know this medium is
tricky and it uh
i'm sorry that i i'm not able to answer
more
immediately but anyway thanks for thanks
for asking and please
please do ask any clarification i'll try
to understand the question better
uh let me just say this right now i was
just describing like a story
uh there's a prover there's a proof the
guy is reading the input and there's
these tossing points
so uh the quantifiers are a bit
hard to they just in the first go so let
me now
repeat it and try to be a bit more
careful and a bit more formal okay
so so far i i in this in this uh square
i wrote two statements but it's not
clear
who's requiring what from whom so let me
uh now state a theorem
okay pcp theorem
okay and the theorem says that there is
a verifier
okay so there is a verifier algorithm
for every
np problem in particular for for graph
recoloring
okay so i can state the theorem for
graph recoloring
graph recoloring has a pcp verifier so
that means there is some algorithm
for the verifier that follows steps
follows steps one one point five
two and three and in the end
uh it satisfies these two uh these two
requirements
uh these two requirements okay so the
pcp theorem says
this every ever
every np
language and i don't think the term np
language is very familiar to people
outside of complexity so let me just say
think of this instead of just read this
as i'm saying
for the problem of three coloring okay
so you can just think of this as three
coloring
or any other np problem you like like
satisfiability
okay every np language has
a verifier
so this is just think of this as just an
algorithm
and but this algorithm has the kind of
interface that is drawn here in the
picture
so the algorithm the input comes from
here
the algorithm has access to some random
point random
coins and the algorithm is reading a
proof from some proof
oracle so there is a verifier
such that okay so
i can uh just copy it again so i just uh
copy
such that on input
such that for every one input
x for for the language but we can think
of it as
a graph g uh the verifier okay how do i
do this
i tried to be very sophisticated yeah
the verifier reads the input so in our
case it's maybe the graph g
then it tosses some random bits log in
if n is the size of g
and then it reads
a very small part of the proof so now i
can actually even specify
trades uh
o of one proof locations
so that's kind of shockingly
reads a very tiny part of the proof
right usually you expect to have to read
the entire three coloring
no this verifier is only going to read
actually very
few bits and then it can it outputs yes
or no
and the so so far i'm just saying every
three
every np language or in particular three
coloring has this kind of algorithm
and what does the algorithm satisfy it
satisfies this
these two conditions
these two conditions which is
that if the input so the verifier
doesn't know i mean the verified gets
the graph g as we said before this is an
np complete problem
uh it can be something or it can be
three coloring so it grabs the graph g
the verifier doesn't know and has no way
of knowing if it's
a three color will graph or not
nevertheless
with the help of the proof it can read
only a tiny part of the proof
and decide if to say yes or no and it it
it has this very different behavior in
both cases so now
it's important the questions that i was
asked the 0.99 here is fixed
for this for this theorem
it doesn't have to do with the size of
the graph g this is for every graph g
and then 0.99 is fixed once and for all
maybe i should have a 0.999
i don't know it doesn't matter and
okay so now what what would this uh
what would this verifier be it is simply
uh the the kind of very simple
algorithm which does the following you
read the graph g
you toss some random coins and based on
them you decide to choose an edge at
random
so that you use the random coins to just
select which edge to read
okay and then you select an edge say u1
u2 you look
at the proof locations corresponding to
u1 and u2
and you read the colors there if the
colors are
different then it looks like a good
proof
so you say yes and if the colors are the
same
you found that someone is trying to
cheat you and you say no
so this is the
pcp verifier except that
there is a problem with this pcp
verifier so
i would say that this is a naive naive
pcb verifier
they choose a random edge
accept if end points
maybe i should write read read colors
from proof
and accept if distinct
if the colors are different so this is
an
epcp verifier and it would work on
graphs that are
not of the type that the example i gave
in the beginning
uh graphs that are not brittle graphs
where
if there are three color we'll find
there is a three coloring there's no
problem
but if they're not recolorable i don't
want them to have these
colorings that are very misleading that
look like
almost all the edges are happy except
for one edge that is unhappy
these graphs are actually problematic
because for such a graph
the probability for such a graph if the
prover
was devious and gave me this kind of
coloring then
the probability that the verifier will
see a problem is only
one out of the e edges so the
the probability here will not be 0.999
it would be
as bad as 1 minus 1 over e
that's kind of the worst
possible that
the proof is very misleading there's
only one edge that
the verifier will catch and every and
then every
on every other edge the verifier will
say yes
only say no on one edge out of all of
the edges
so 1 minus 1 over e when e is the size
of the graph
this goes almost to 1. whereas in my
in the theorem i'm saying that the
probability is bounded by some constant
a fraction okay so
how do i uh fix this
instead of running the naive verifier on
the initial graph we first
go back to where we were in the
beginning and we first
run the pcp mapping on our graph to get
a new graph g tilde
that we know is not brutal remember that
we had this transformation if i scroll
up we had this transformation
and this algorithm here i am over here
that takes a graph g into a new graph g
tilde
and in the new graph i'm guaranteed that
if g
was not recolorable then g tilde doesn't
have any problematic
colorings all the colorings always
violate at least one percent of the
edges
so what a naive verifier should do is
first
run the pcp transformation on g and then
expect this proof not a three coloring
for g but rather as three coloring for g
tilde
okay so i'm going back going back
okay so uh
the pecp theorem was proven in the uh
beginning of the 90s i guess 90 or 91.
um and uh
it immediately kind of uh well
had many different consequences but uh
one thing was uh it was very shocking to
think about this that a proof
for three colorability or for any other
np problem
can be verified by reading only a
constant number of bits
kind of very counterintuitive so this
was one aspect it was
quite incredible and another aspect
is that this is very much related to
hardness of approximation which is
what i want to describe described now
so maybe before i move on let me just
pause for a minute
to see if there are any more questions
can you see the questions that were
asked because there were a lot of them
but many of them have already been or
all of them have already been answered
in the chat
oh okay i cannot see anything
unfortunately i had some wi-fi problems
and i cannot
uh okay i'm only seeing my ipad screen
yeah
okay so i guess the the protocol that
we're taking with questions is if one of
the panelists wants to answer it live
then they will
then they will interrupt you and
otherwise we'll answer them
all right cool so let me so
risking uh repeating answers that were
given in the chat
uh let me just mention a couple of
things here
[Music]
there are some parameters that are
natural to consider for the verifier so
let me
talk about them before i move to
hardness of approximation
and that will be probably uh the end of
today's lecture
[Music]
parameters of the verifier
so uh
one thing is the number of
queries to the proof
so we said that in the pcb theorem the
verifier reads a constant number of
symbols from the proof but what is this
constant okay so that's one parameter
another parameter is the alphabet of the
proof
so alphabet in the sense of coding
theory
it's maybe the most basic is to think of
the proof as written in bits but for
example in three coloring
it's natural to write the proof in the
alphabet of way zero one two
and uh in other cases it's natural to go
to an even larger alphabet because it
allows other parameters to become better
and we'll see this now
a third parameter uh okay we say this
soon but first let me
talk about the number of random coins
the number of random bits used by the
verifier so we said of log n
but actually uh
as long as it's of log n this
corresponds to a polynomial
size transformation but of course if
it's one times log n this will be a
linear
transformation that's a one thread of a
research is trying to get this say
to be as efficient as possible uh
okay i won't say any more about this
today um
final parameters are the completeness
and soundness
so completeness these are the two
probabilities
the completeness and soundness are these
two probabilities over here
completeness is the probability
of saying yes when you're supposed to
say yes
okay so let's just only treat the case
right now that it's one
often it's close to one like one minus
epsilon
uh sometimes it's other values
and the soundness is the probability to
say yes when you're supposed to say no
if the graph is not recolorable really
what you want the verifier is to always
say no
but okay this cannot be done so you
measure the soundness what is the
probability of saying
yes falsu and here we wrote the sounds
to be 0.999
so okay that's one pcb verifier and it
has soundness of 0.999
you might ask okay but i want to know
what is the best possible soundness that
i can guarantee
can i get 0.998 and so on so that's the
completeness and soundness and we often
care about
trying to understand the trade-offs
between these various
parameters
okay so now let me move to talk about
hardness of approximation
okay
so in general when we think about
approximation we should first talk about
optimization problems
in optimization problem you're trying to
find the best solution the solution
say for recoloring i should think about
max recall
i prefer to give an example and talk
about it then to give a
generic definition so i'm sticking to
this example
max recall in this case would be the
problem of given a graph
find the coloring of the vertices that
maximizes the fraction of edges that are
bichromatic
well that's a maximization problem
you can think of others for example
given a system of equations
find an assignment to the variables that
maximizes the fraction of satisfied
equations
all of these are very similar and again
like i said in the beginning there are
examples of
constraint satisfaction problems
okay so we already know that this
optimization problem is
np-hard because we know that it's hard
and be hard to decide
if the value if you can satisfy a
hundred percent of the
edge constraints or less than percent so
we know it's
np hard for this case
okay you can think about max three in
so max thrilling is the problem of you
have a bunch of linear equations
over the field of two elements zero and
one
and maybe each equation only has three
variables so they're very simple
equations
and still uh
your task is to find an assignment that
satisfies
the largest fraction of equations in
this case unlike the three coloring case
to decide if the whole system is
satisfiable or not it's very easy
it's you just need to invert that matrix
um but the optimization problem to find
the maximal
solution maximizing the fraction of good
equations
actually this is an np hard and the
reason is that the equations can be over
determined it can be the case that there
is no solution to all the equations
and then these algorithms like gaussian
elimination they just fail
and it turns out that this is np hard
to maximize
and there almost every csp you think
about
is np hard to next to and to
optimize over and so it's natural to
think about approximation algorithms
which is
an algorithm that uh is supposed to give
you a weaker guarantee
okay it won't find the maximal solution
but it will find a solution that
maybe is guaranteed to be within 98
of the maximum okay so that's an
approximation algorithm
and the pcp theorem says that even
approximation is np-hard for these kinds
of the
constrained satisfaction problems so the
pcp
theorem implies that
even even
sorry about this
so here i'm just going to give us an
example max three call
and the reason is as we sign the pcp
theorem
it's going to be np hard to decide if a
graph is perfectly recolorable or if
the maximal fraction is no more than
0.99
we already know
it's np hard to decide
between
a the value of g is one
or the value of g is less than 0.99
and here the the value is this
is the maximal fraction of satisfied
edges when i say satisfied i mean
bichromatic
so this was one formulation of the tcp
theorem that these two things
it's np hard to tell between them and so
if i had an approximation algorithm that
approximates to within 0.999 i would
give this algorithm the graph g and
it would give me some value that's
within a small
margin of error which would allow me to
distinguish between these two cases
so such a statement actually proves to
me
hardness of the or the non-existence of
approximation algorithms
assuming p is different from np so these
are always
all these uh hardness statements are
always assuming that
of course that p is different from np
okay and now we get to this value of
0.99
okay and uh okay actually so
i'm going to end in 10 minutes and i
want to leave a few minutes at the end
to
to give a roadmap to the talks that will
come so
okay i'm actually i'm doing pretty good
on time so i will
finish this in a few minutes and then i
will talk about what's what
will be in the next few talks um
okay so now i'm getting to the parameter
0.99 and how it relates
it doesn't relate to the specific g but
it does relate to the specific
oops problem at hand max recall okay
so if if instead of max recoloring i
would have here a different
problem for example maximizing linear
equations
you could expect that this number might
be
different and it is and here's a very
celebrated theorem
of johann hastad
which says uh
actually for some uh specific problems
like
threesat and thrilling i know the exact
constant that needs to be here
so not i know but hasta knows so
um for three lean
and similarly for three sat
has no non-trivial
approximation algorithm
okay so i won't have time too much to go
into it we will talk about it probably
in the last lecture but
uh for example for three lean you have a
bunch of linear equations over boolean
variables
it's very easy to see that you can
always satisfy half the equations
if some assignment satisfied less than
half then just flipping all the bits
will satisfy more than half something
like that what i said is not completely
correct but
it's actually very easy to see maybe you
you can do a probabilistic argument to
say that in expectation
each equation is satisfied with
probability half so there must be
an assignment that satisfies more than
half of the equations
so it's always very easy to satisfy half
of the equations
and what has that proved is that
um okay let me actually just erase reset
for now and what has to prove
is that actually it is np hard
to decide
if the value of the equations
the given system of equations is above
one minus epsilon
or if the value is at most half plus
epsilon
and this is for every epsilon
okay so you're given a system of boolean
equations with each equation with three
variables
and and it's hard to tell between almost
100 percent and almost 50 percent so in
that sense there's no non-trivial
approximation algorithm
and similarly for threesat and today we
know
that uh the picture is even more subtle
that it's not really just the random
assignment
but really the the value that
distinguishes between these two cases is
the
sdp value and when i say know this
is i mean that the sdp value is the
correct soundness
soundness parameter
here and when i say i know this so a
prasad rag ventral proved this assuming
the unique games conjecture so
we still don't know this for a fact but
it's conjectured that we know the
correct value
up to this up to this open question
okay so let me uh let me just summarize
what i said about
the hardness of approximation i just
said that the pcp theorem
in in its standard form is equivalent to
some statement about the hardness of
approximation
for example of three coloring but you
can run it also on
other problems like on three lean or on
three sat many other np
problems you you can interpret the pcp
theorem as a statement about hardness of
approximation
you will get some parameter like here we
got this 0.99
i i kind of just made it up from the
theorem you will get some worse constant
like 0.99999
and then i said that has to prove a much
stronger pcp theorem
we call it's a tight it's a tight pcp
theorem
it's tight because the the parameter
that that he got is
is the best possible there's an
algorithm showing you cannot do more
than
you cannot do better than that and so we
know for some problems
that what is the exact tight parameter
and there's a huge amount of work on
this
and when you try to look at tight
parameters you encounter many
geometrical
questions and this will be described in
the next
maybe this will be described actually in
the last lecture on monday
so uh now let me
finish by giving you a little bit of a
road map is where we're going with this
sequence of talks so the way i wanted to
say it is to ask
how are the theorems the pcp theorem
in hastag's theorem
proven okay
and even further theorems right so
tomorrow on on lecture two
donna will talk she will give her a
proof of a
basic pcp theorem it's even it's weaker
than
the the the pcp theorem that
i mentioned here this is what we call
the
the the basic pcp theorem then i will
give a proof of a week a week pcp
theorem
i mean there's so much you can expect
her to prove in one hour
so this would already be quite an
accomplishment
okay then in lecture three i will talk
about
kind of uh how to prove how to prove a
stronger pcp theorem
a using a kind of a tensor tensor
operation
which we call parallel repetition
so i will talk about this operation
which takes one
pcp theory and maybe strengthens it
and this is important both because there
are some very interesting geometrical
questions
high dimensional geometry questions here
that we thought might be interesting to
tell you about but also because this is
a kind of initial step towards
uh proving hashtags results because he
uses this kind of
theorem combined with something called
the long code gadget
which will be a key player in the last
lecture where donald will talk
about a unique games conjecture
and the long code and
all kinds of ezo parametric questions
that are right guys
when you try to prove a hardness of
approximation
so when you try to prove tight hardness
of approximation like in hostage theorem
but you know more general and
more applicable applicable to more
problems then you reach all of these
interesting
questions and that will be the last
lecture
so stay tuned
okay so uh thank you for the great
lecture and uh
so jesse has just put a link in the chat
to the discord channel so we can all go
on to discord now
and maybe after a break for stretching
and or coffee or tea
we can discuss what we like and then
we'll reconvene later
for ramon's talk